يقول
تعالى في كتابه الكريم هو الذي يريكم
البرق خوفا وطمعا وينشئ السحاب
الثقال ويسبح الرعد بحمده والملائكه من
خيفته ويرسل الصواعق فيصيب بها من
يشاء وهم يجادلون في الله وهو شديد
المحال
قوله تعالى هو
الذي هذه الجمل
كلها
بدل من قوله تعالى يعلم ما تحمل كل
انثى قال تعالى الله يعلم ما تحمل كل انثى
والجمله التي تليها عالم الغيب والشهاده
والتي بعدها له
معقبات وهو الذي
يريكم فالتقدير الله يعلم ما تحمل كل انثى
الله عالم الغيب والشهاده
الله له
معقب الله هو الذي يري كم البرق خوفا
وطمعا الله له معقبات في قول بعض المفسرين
وبعض السلف رحمهم الله
تعالى قوله تعالى هو الذي يريكم
البرقه خوفا
وطمعا البرق
والضوء اللامع المعروف الذي يخرج
من
السحاب والله عز وجل يري عباده البرق خوفا
وطمعا
خوفا قيل للمسافر وطمعا
للمقيم
والصحيح
خوفا بان الانسان يخاف هذه البروق
وهذه
الكهرباء التي يراها
والتي من اصابته هلك من طبع
الانسان يقول وطمعا اي
يطمع
عباده
ب ما يريهم من البرق ذلك ان
الانسان خاصه في
الصحاري ينظر فيرى البرق
بعيدا
يلمع فانه
تاخذه
خوف وايضا
يطمع لان البرق علام على مجيء المطر باذن
الله فانه اذا راى ذلك اطمان بان
المطر
مقبل والذي يريك البرق خوفا
وطمعا وينشئ السحاب الثقال ينشئ
يخلق
ويكون
السحاب
الثقال وهي ثقيله بالمطر بالامطار
بالماء كيف يرفع الله سبحانه وتعالى هذا
الثقل
فوق الانسان وفوق الهواء شيء
عجيب ودليل على عظيم قدره الله سبحانه
وتعالى وان الله تعالى يرع من يشاء ويضع
من
يشاء وانه سبحانه وتعالى علام
الغيوب وهذه الامطار التي هي معلقه من فوق
رؤوسنا فهي في
الحقيقه تخوف
وتطمع يقول تعالى ويسبح الرعد
بحمده الرعد وذا
الصوت الذي ينشى
عقب البرق
والبروق هذا الرعد يسبح
بحمده قيل
الرعد قال بعض المفسرين الرعد هو
الملك
الموكل
وذلك اشاره الى حديث اخرجه الامام الترمذي
وغيره اسناد حسن لغيره او حسن
لذاته عن ابن عباس رضي الله تعالى
عنهما ان جماعه من اليهود جاؤوا النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم في
المدينه يسالونه ثلاثه
اسئله يزعمون
الا يعلم
جوابه الا نبي
مرسل فاخذ النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
ميثاقهم وعهدهم لئن اجابهم
ليؤمنن فسالوه ومنن ضمن هذه هذه الاسئله
سالوه ما
البرق فاخبر صلى الله عليه وسلم انه
ملك ذو
صوت يزجر
السحاب باذن
الله هذه روايه
صحيحه صحيحه
بمعنى الذي الصحه التي تقابل الضعف والا
في الروايه من ناحيه
السند اسناده
حسن فالسؤال هل هذا
ينافي ما يظن من العلم
الحديث من
اسباب صوت
الرعد
وانه الانفجار الذي يكون وال الاكسجين اي
هذه التفاعلات التي تكون الجواب لا هذا لا
ينافي هذا
ابدا المسائل التي
فيها ذكر للغيبيات
لا تنافي المشهدا ابدا ما في تنافي بينهما
على الاطلاق لذلك الصحابه رضي الله عنهم
لم يسالوا هذه
الاسئله
فهذا شيء وهذا شيء ولا مانع من ان يعمل
هذا مع
هذا النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اخبر عن
مالك واخبر عن رضوان في بعض الاثار واخبر
عن
اسرافيل واخبر
عن ميكائيل
الذي يبعثه الله
تعالى وكيلا
على
الامطار وعلى النبات فهل هذا ينافي ما
نعلمه من احوال النبات الجواب لا الصحابه
رضي الله عنهم كانوا فلاحين
ماهرين ما حدا سال لما اخبره النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم عن ميكائيل كيف يا رسول
الله يكون ذلك وانما نحن نعلم اننا اذا
فعلنا كان كذا ما ما حدا سال هذا السؤال
لان هذا لا ينافي هذا
ابدا فعلى كل حال في هذه
الروايه النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم اخبر ان
هذا
الرعد وهذا البرق الذي يرى هو
صوت
صوت هذا الملك فبعض العلماء
قال الرعد هو اسم الملك
نفسه وبعضهم قال بل
اسم لهذا الصوت الذي يسمع وعلى كل
حال
فقوله تعالى ويسبح الرعد
بحمده كل شيء في السماوات وفي الارض يسبح
بحمد الله وان من شيء الا يسبح بحمده ولكن
لا تفقهون
تسبيحهم العلماء اختلفوا ما هذا التسبيح
هل هو تسبيح فعلا مثل ما
نحن
التسبيح وكل تسبيح على حسب ما يليق
بالمسبح يعني مثلا الانسان يليق بلساننا
ان نقول سبحان الله وبحمده ان ننطق بهذه
المعاني
واما غيرنا من خلق الله فيسبح بلغه او
باسلوب
يناسب او ان التسبيح هنا
بمعنى انه
بمجرد قيامه
ووجوده و
بخلقه
فانه
ا يسبح بحمد الله سبحانه وتعالى وهذا
اشبه وايا كان فالر يسبح
خاصه يسبح تسبيحا
نسمعه
ويخوف ان الانسان اذا سمع الرعد
تذكر فيقول ويسبح الرعد بحمده
بحمده يعني يسبح الرعد متلبسا بحمد
الله يعني سبحان الله
وبحمده
التسبيح هو التنزيه
تقول سبحان الله
اي تنزه الله سبحانه وتعالى عن كل نقص
وعيب
والحمد هو العكس هو الضد من ذلك هو
اثبات كل
فضيله فالتسبيح
تنزيه وال حمد اثبات اثبات
الكمال جاء في حديث ابي مالك الاشعري عند
مسلم ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال وسبحان الله والحمد لله تمان او تملا
ما بين السماء والارض روايه معروفه مشهوره
ذكرها النووي رحمه الله في الاربعين
لماذا تملا ما بين السماء
والارض لان اذا الانسان جمع بين التسبيح
الذي هو تنزيه الله عن
النقائص واضاف الى التسبيح التحميد الذي
هو اثبات كل كمال
لله فكل فعل وكل مخلوق وكل شيء والسماوات
والارض
فانها تتهلل
بتسبيح الله بحمده سبحانه
وتعالى فقوله تعالى ويسبح الرعد
بحمده
بحمده لما الانسان يقول سبحان الله
وبحمده انت
تقول انزه الله عن كل نقص وعيب مع اثبات
كل كمال له انت هذا هو تفسير هذه الكلمه
العظيمه يقول صلى الله عليه
وسلم
كلمتان خفيفتان على اللسان ثقيلتان في
الميزان حبيبتان الى الرحمن سبحان الله
وبحمده
سبحان الله العظيم
اخر حديث رواه الامام البخاري في
صحيح اول
حديث انما الاعمال
بالنيات واخر
حديث سبحان الله وبحمده فعلى كل
حال ف قه ويسبح الرعد
بحمده الانسان يسبح الله بحمد
يعني متلبسا بحمد الله لما الانسان يقول
سبحان الله بعد الصلاه سبحان الله يستحضر
هذه النيه ستحضر هذه المعاني انزه الله
اللهم اني اشهدك انني اشهد بنزاهته من كل
عيب
ونقص وتقول الحمد
لله كان انك تقول اللهم اني
اشهدك
واشهد ان لك كل
كمال
سبحانك ف التسبيح بدون
التحميد او التحميد بدون
التسبيح لا يصلح لما الانسان يقول سبحان
الله المسلم فان انه لا ينزه الله عن كل
شيء ينزه الله عن كل شيء نزه الله منه
نفسه واذا قال الحمد لله فانك لا تثبت لله
كل شيء تثبت له ما اثبته الله لنفسه لان
ثم
اشياء هي فينا كمال وفي الله
نقص يعني مثلا
الولد
الانسان الذي لا ولد له هذا نقص اليس كذلك
للانسان ولله
وكمال
وكذلك
النوم ياتي انسان يقول لا استطيع النوم
هذا كمال ولا نقص هذا نقص في الانسان كمال
في الرب سبحانه
وتعالى كذلك في الاخلاق يعني
الكبرياء كمال في الانسان بل نقص في
الانسان هذا يدل على جهل
الانسان نقص في الانسان كمال في الله
سبحانه وتعالى وهلم جره فالانسان يثبت
وينفي حسب تعليم القران
والسنه يقول تعالى سبح الرعد بحمده
والملائكه يعني
والملائكه تسبح
بحمده من
خيفته
هنا بمعنى السببيه يعني بسبب خيفته بسبب
خوفهم سبحانه وتال
والملائكه اذا علمنا من عظمه
الملائكه وان الملائكه
تسبح بحمد الله من
خيفته فهذا ينبئ عن عظمه الله سبحانه
وتعالى ويرسل
الصواعق
والصواعق جمع صاعقه والصاعقه في القران
تطلق على الشرر الذي
ينزل من
السحاب
واصل
الصعق في لغه العرب
الموت قال
تعالى واذ قلتم يا موسى لن نؤمن لك حتى
نرى الله جهره
فاخذتكم الصاعقه يعني الموت ليس معناه
الصاعقه
يعني لمعه البرق او الكهربا باء من لا
الله عز وجل ذكر في سوره
الاعراف
انهم اهلكهم الله سبحانه وتعالى
بالرجفه لكن الصاعقه هنا يعني
الموت والعرب
تسمي هذا
البرق الذي يرى وينزل من
السحاب
يسمونه
بصاعقه
والصواعق من باب تسميه الشيء
بلازمه يعني الذي يصعق يموت هذه صاعقه هي
الموت كما ان العرب يسمون
السم
الموت اليس كذلك يسمون السم
الموت
ف قوله تعالى ويرسل
الصواعق فيصيب بها من
يشاء وهم يجادلون في الله يعني
والحال هذه الصواعق وهذا هو الله او هذا
طر من عظمه
الله ومع هذا حالهم انهم يجادلون في الله
وهو شديد المحال فهذه الجمله جمله ايش
جمله
حاليه يعني هم يفعلون
هذا من جهلهم بعظمه الله سبحانه وتعالى مع
ان الحال ان الله تعالى هو كيت
وكيت
وهم يجادلون في
الله يعني يجادلون في الله في توحيد الله
سبحانه
وتعالى النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم ياتيهم
بلا اله الا الله من خلق السماوات والارض
يقولون الله من خلق كذا وكذا من الرازق من
الكذا من الكذا يقولون الله
فتقول لهم اذا اعبدوا الله وحده لا لا
نفعل ان هذا لشيء
عجاب هم يجادلون في
الله تدعوهم الى عباده الله
وحده وهم يثبتون لله كل هذه
العظمه لكنهم يجادلون بعد
ذلك ان الله تعالى يستحق للعباد وحده دون
ما سواه وانه يبعثهم بعد الموت يستبعدون
هذه
وهذه هذا هو الشيء العجيب لذلك يقول وان
تعجب فعجب
قولهم
في اول السوره يقول وان تعجب ان تعجب من
انهم يثبتون يعلمون كل هذه العظمه
لله فاعجب من هذا كفرهم به بعد هذا العلم
هذا اعجب فعلا واعلموا ان الله يحول بين
المرء
وقلبه
و قوله تعالى وهم يجادلون في الله وهو
شديد
المحال شديد
المحال يعني شديد
القوه او شديد الاخذ سبحانه
وتعالى لمن
اخذ فالله سبحانه
وتعالى هم يجادلون
فيه هم يجادلون في الله وهو شديد
المحال يعني هو سبحانه وتعالى والحال انه
سبحانه وتعالى شديد شد المحال شديد
المؤاخذه اذا اخذ
عبده ولكنه سبحانه وتعالى
حليم لذلك لا يعاجل عباده العصاه في
المؤاخذه والله عز
وجل يؤخر الناس
لاجل
مسمى اذا انقضى اجل
الانسان واقيم بين يدي الله
هنالك يؤاخذ الله سبحانه وتعالى بكل صغيره
وكبيره ان
شاء
والانسان
بين عدل
الله وبين فضل الله ورحمه الله نسال الله
سبحانه وتعالى ان يعاملنا برحمته وان لا
يؤاخذنا بعدله سبحانه
وتعالى فالله سبحانه
وتعالى هو شديد المحال لكنه حليم
سبحانه وكذلك الله سبحانه وتعالى لا يبدل
القول
لديه يعني هو سمى اجلا لكل المخلوقات وسمى
وسمى يوما لقاء بين يدي الله فهو لا يؤخذ
او لا
يعاجل
الناس
بمعاصيهم قبل
ذلك
لكن جاء في حديث ابي موسى
الاشعري ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم قال
ان الله ليملي للظالم
حتى اذا
اخذه لم
يفلته قال وكذلك اخذ ربك اذا اخذ القرى
وهي ظالمه ان اخذه اليم شديد نسال الله
تعالى
العافيه وكذلك جاء في المسند مسند الامام
احمد ان النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال اذا رايت
الله يعطي العبد على معاصيه من الدنيا ما
يحب فاعلم انما هو
استدراج ونست درج من حيث لا يعلمون واملي
لهم ان كيدي
متين فالله سبحانه وتعالى
يصبر على اذى سمعه يدعون يدعون له
الولد
والصاحبه وهو سبحانه وتعالى يرزقهم
ويعافيه فماذا ترى انه يصنع باصحاب كلمه
لا اله الا
الله بالمؤمنين بالمسلمين هو
وهكذا
فعاله مع غير المسلمين فكيف مع المسلمين
رحمته واسعه لكن واسعه لمن
طلبها ليس
لمن
اعرض عن ذكره
سبحانه نكتفي بهذا القدر والله اعلم وصلى
الله وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى علىه واصحه
اعين سه
الر الله سبحانه
وتعالى translates
toing and he is the
one
who
‏as a an
incen and as illicit of fear and
hope and he as well creates these very
heavy suspended clouds so الله سبحانه
وتالى البق
‏meaning light it act to elicit in us
fear and it elicit in us
hope fear
of the
fire they cause fear of the destruction
or the vicious of the storms that could
be
brewing but also
hope because we understand that in such
clouds
‏our
and blood of our earth which is and
water and wind pollination and all of
these posi things that come as a of
these
storms these things are
especially
prent to people in
deser ‏was
first if you imag with in the deser
there not very
raining and so الله سبحانه
وتالى land theate us the environment
as a
‏we as human
being
are when we are awaiting our sustenance
when we
are feeling we are being stretched
to our absolute breaking point and then
when the rain comes down the the
landes and takes
‏even a hours was
in sh and was totally hopeless now once
this water came down and was taken into
this earth and into this ground and the
vegetation comes up and it is lush and
and
life
‏green and after
that thriving life comes
inevitable and then
transformation and the process over
these are
all الله سبحانه
وتعالى
قران ‏that these are parables analogies
of our world of our
lives of our existence so سبحانه وتالى
and is
the shows the light to to
elicit fear and
hope and he likewise
creates these
lof billowing heavy clouds
سبحانه وتعالى
next ويسبح
الرعد
indeed the
thunder
boom
with the glory and praise
allah and the angs
as out ofar
الله he men
angels which are parag str in
قران and then he mentions their
fear doesn't mean that the angels are
not treated well by allah
سعال hope
الله merc
الله الله سبحانه
وتى قر ‏are considered to a sym
of and they are paragons of absolute
strength in the creation of
allah and
so these most creatures of allah
numerous creatures of
allah the most
prominent fe with to their
سبحانه
وتالى the light
strikes and he afflicts with them whom
he
chooses seem to us very random but in
they are incred
pr
nothing
الله وكل شي عنده
بمقدار
great me
الله سبحانه وتالى send
thees
andou
‏a storm whether it be a light storm or
rain or tornado or hurricane any kind of
storm there are few things which are
symbols of pure chos and
randomness than a stm stm ‏when we look
at it it looks incredibly
random it looks it is just a a
vicious vient happ where things
arbit الله سبحانه وتالى tells
قران that in
out these storms are
incred الله سبحانه
وتعالى that ‏that not one thing happ in
the of such ch
except ex الله سبحانه
وتعالى
me وهم يجادلون
في
‏alls to الله debate disbeliever debate
صلى الله عليه وسلم
arate what are they debating what argu
arguing that he not be the only wor
سبحانه
و aru that id wor
‏all
that ar that الله not
wor
can revive
human
res human
‏human
human day are
ar
الله
very
tak سبحانه
وتالى وصلى وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله
واصحابه
اجمعين